hello this is presh talwalkar
and this is part two of the five part
series on how to solve the rubik's cube
in this video we're going to go over the
move notation which will be extremely
important to understanding the sequences
of moves in the layer method
before we get started solving the cube i
want to explain
rubik's cube move notation
this will be extremely important for
following the directions in the
remaining videos
we orient the cube
dependent on the face we're looking at
if we rotate the face we're looking at
90 degrees clockwise
that move is called f
if we do f a second time that rotates at
90 degrees clockwise once more
this is f a third time
and here's f a fourth time which brings
the front face back to its original
position
if we rotate the front face 90 degrees
counterclockwise
that's known as f prime or f inverse
and similarly we can keep doing this
multiple times
so here's f prime done three times
and here's f prime
for a fourth time
the other sides of the cube
are given positions relative to the face
we're looking at
for example
if we look at the face to the right
of the face we're looking at the side to
the right of what we're looking at
a 90 degrees clockwise move
is denoted r for right
we can repeat the move of r four times
and bring
the right
side back to the original position
there's also the move of r prime or r
inverse
which is a 90 degrees counterclockwise
move
the side which is on the left of what
we're looking at
we can move it the move l is a 90
degrees clockwise move relative to that
face so after repeatedly doing l four
times we get back to the original
position
l prime is counterclockwise
and we can repeatedly do that move
to change
the left side
the side which is on the top
or up
this is the move u which is a 90 degrees
clockwise move
and here we bring u once more and bring
it back to the original
position
if we rotate the upper face 90 degrees
counterclockwise that's u prime or u
inverse
finally
there's the side which is down
the bottom side will call down so the
move of d is a 90 degrees clockwise move
of the bottom
side of the cube relative to what we're
looking at
similarly if we go counterclockwise 90
degrees
that will be down inverse or down prime
there's also a back face and you could
similarly add notation to that but we're
not going to need it for any of the
moves in our videos
i hope you like this video please click
through to watch the next video which
explains how to solve the first layer of
the cube
please subscribe to my channel
you can support me on patreon for
exclusive rewards catch me on my blog
mind your
on twitter at preshtalwalkar and you can
get my books listed on my website